when did you start hiring white guys to
protect you yeah when too much black
guys were dying
employed it was just wait really
funny Charlemagne said that to me no
he's like dude he's like dude I'm
telling you you know that I'm safe if
there's a guy with if a white dude is in
like a suit
and he has like a
a legal gun yeah like he's like yeah
that's how you know I've actually made
it when my security guards have legal
guns yeah yeah yeah yeah but does he
have a gun he doesn't need a gun out
here I don't think you have guns out
here like that it can't be legal gun for
sure
yeah you can I think you can have legal
going to security but you gotta
I think they carry them when they're
looking after like politicians and stuff
like that ah so the police don't even
get to carry a gun police carry guns
they do yeah yeah not not every police I
saw this documentary about being a cop
in the UK it's called Luther I don't
know if you've seen it they did not have
guns in this documentary yeah the last
code though
in that show yeah yeah we got like tried
and that you know like the gun police
and stuff like that you get a trident me
like yeah we got like certain branches
of police stuff
from The Little Mermaid I'm like dude
this is next level
dude okay yeah we're still understanding
like the gun culture here I think that
was the trickiest thing for you know for
top boy for me is it like the idea was
like these like gangsters who was out in
the street and they were like sharing
weapons and stuff like that and like to
me like weapons are just so available
everyone's got one yeah yes like even a
non-gangster mo
uh maybe like shotguns some Farmers or
some [ __ ] like that yeah yeah but no not
everyone's walking around for gun really
yeah and then when the farmers like you
got so brave in road rage
way more fun yeah yeah but when you're
in America they're like don't argue with
no one yeah that's true like yeah that
guy might just have a guy I grew up in
Texas everybody has a gun and they say
don't honk at anybody because that guy
might get pissed off also the nicest
people in Texas yeah yeah right think
about it the more guns Yeah the more hey
hey y'all how you doing yeah New York
not that many guns yeah go [ __ ] yourself
the New York laws are different yeah
there's yeah you're very strict okay
because it's there's so many people
around there's gonna be more
interactions where you want to shoot
somebody you guys with a gun thing you
you with it or you think that needs to
change I'm with me having it yeah
white security with a gun
want to hold it but I do want a guy like
you holding a gun like the guy you had
Frank is that his name they're all Frank
to me
every British white guy is Frank yeah
okay he wants a Frank I want a Frank
right because if a guy came up to you
like if somebody's harassing you and
then like that guy just walked up like a
[ __ ] bowling pin just came up and
he's like all right enough
yeah it's enough it's enough he's got to
be he's gonna be British too I feel like
with the accent you can scrap yeah right
out of the what's the guy's movie uh
which one guy Richie oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a good one right guy
Richie was um snatching and it's not
snatched Lock Stock Two Smoking Barrels
two girls one cup
that was a good one that was a good one
right yeah yeah he's great with that
yeah yeah he's he's I love his work yeah
guy Richie is just in there so what do
you see from English culture like before
like top boy or whatever or hearing the
music before I I don't think before any
we didn't I didn't know that you broke
the law yeah but so what would you see
from England football or something yeah
yeah we thought y'all were a bit [ __ ]
yeah okay well here's the thing I didn't
think you guys were [ __ ] I said I use
past tense I thought you had everything
you needed yeah you know what I mean
like it's like
you get the house from the government
right if you're not if you're out of a
job yeah Council house yeah yeah they
give you the house yeah so like and then
you have health care yeah yeah so then
like when people are out there robbing
I'm just like why are you being greedy
yeah you're greedy you know yeah America
America like someone steals my jacket
I'm like are you cold
is there ever part of that growing up
where you're like ah maybe we shouldn't
do that
the government's so nice yeah I don't
know it's like it's mad because
I I guess
like when you you don't know any bit you
don't know any different yeah you know
what I mean it is what it is so if you
haven't got any money you just haven't
got any money but sometimes you don't
really see
you know like your other countries can't
go to the hospital if they get sick you
know yeah it's like so we're privileged
in that sense you know I mean but you
don't really see it because that's all
we know yeah you know poverty is
relative yeah it's relative yeah it's
relative but Council housing what you
don't have Council housing we do a
section eight we call it back home like
listen they're not gonna like let you
live on the streets but like people are
a little bit more desperate it feels
like yeah you know yeah like it's like
my mother's from Scotland right and she
said there are people who just go on I
think it's called the Dole yeah right
like she had family members it's like
all right we're not going to really work
and that's this is the new job which is
the Dole yeah yeah though and I guess we
have welfare but it doesn't seem like we
have a lot more homeless than here yeah
we really don't have that many homes
yeah maybe it's the weather maybe the
rain keeps them out we gotta find a way
to yeah
make the weather more rainy back home
please Shane the way I said I'd rather
be rich in America but poor here oh
you know what I'm saying I think there
are people who will move back home
I think my mom even said that once she's
like I know if it doesn't work out there
I can always go back home I know people
whose family members come here when they
need a certain operation you know I mean
that they can just go to a e for and get
it taken care of yeah or like a girl has
like a kid in the states or somebody
doesn't work out comes back here what
happened bro
wait did that happen with you
relax Frank relax
did that happen no it did it after did
you knock up an American Girl no are you
sure I'm very
sure I don't know if you're that sure
dude I'm sure some of the girls here
they don't got the best looking women
out there how long you been there yeah
how long you've been here
24 hours
where have you been uh don't know
tonight
but Al what are you into what type of
girls do you like uh the pretty ones the
pretty ones pretty girls here they were
beautiful last night what are you
talking about yeah I like stuff they
were with us you mean the ones that I we
brought there was one
shortage house uh Sushi Samba on the
60th floor
and you did you weren't you didn't find
the women attractive really yeah why is
this I mean what do you mean why is this
I didn't find him attractive but but
like there wasn't one that passed no do
you think there's just something that
happens here in the water and then right
it's like it's not I try to get shot by
dude
I've never seen how intimidated ever
talking about my mother
okay now you've traveled obviously do
you think the women get better looking
in other areas
[Laughter]
typically American women very beautiful
English women not as much you think my
mom's from Scotland your mom great tits
I mean it's facts bro why do you think
I'm six too you should have been sucking
more
you suck yourself to five seven I need
you to grow up you know I stayed on that
tit till I was like 14.
but no for real my mom my mom is a very
attractive woman from Scotland like a
six in America but like a Scottish
the conversion rate was tough back in
the day
my mom's a dime dude my mom's a [ __ ]
dime
but no she's you know she's a hot chick
smoking hot chick from Scotland I think
British women are very attractive I
don't know what you're saying but maybe
you maybe you don't like um freckles Al
is that it but when you say British you
mean like
[Music]
yeah yeah but there are certain women
here that they look like the fish at the
bottom of the ocean like that
translucent angler fish
[Laughter]
we have them too back home like a
Portland in Portland
San Francisco disgusting women yeah but
like real yes
when I say this it's the [ __ ]
weirdest thing but it's but it is a
little thing here so we're not saying
it's specific to you know London I think
the women here are beautiful I think
you're a racist
no there's different rules man there's
different racial rules isn't it
like is anybody here black or is it
like what the [ __ ] I'm about to make
sense
would you identify first as black yeah
or do you go I'm Jamaican yes or
Nigerian or whatever
like the way I'm Indian not brown yeah
and not Asian yeah
no
I would say I'm black you would start
with black yeah I thought that was an
American yeah me too yeah
but yeah but then yeah
yeah Jamaican Caribbean so it goes black
Jamaican
British black British and Jamaican
you're a black British yeah yeah my
mom's born in Jamaica
do you ever wish you were just American
bro
do you ever sit back and wish sometimes
I wish I was born in Jamaica really why
I don't know did you ever live there did
you get to film out there never yeah I
filmed that there just not for the show
no I wasn't a part of those scenes but
I've done other stuff out there in there
but but I don't know man it's just like
yeah I love it I went there a lot as a
kid spent a lot of time we used to go
there for the six weeks for the holidays
and all of that yeah so I spent loads of
time love it hmm yeah love it I think a
lot of people in London really connect
with like where their parents are from
yes you know that's kind of what I'm
trying to see that Less in America yeah
you know a lot of people that I forget
they're American right well
unfortunately because you know the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] America they don't really
know what to connect with yeah so they
could 23 and me and be like oh you're
from the Congo it's not like they can
like haul somebody up in the Congo yeah
and be like what happened back in the
day yeah that I'm here but people live
in it yeah
right but people here really have like a
a direct connection you know whether
you're Indian or Jamaican or Africa well
typically you're probably one generation
deep maybe two right there's not people
that are here like four or five
generations who are like oh I'm Jamaican
that's it yeah was the neighborhood you
grew up in with a lot of like Caribbeans
the neighborhood I can't believe I said
neighborhood what do you call it the
road
oh the ends yeah yeah but area I grew up
in was probably
majority Indian oh really yeah he's up
yeah